after turning into a duck cry one over
two pewds and said it's okay come I'll
take you to my dear home how many subs
more traumatic I liked it he cared for
worked in little pews into his arms and
started walking
Pew's looked at cry with big eyes yeah
you know we have known it for a long
time now we started to suspect something
when you try to hook up with a swine
Peter started blushing I was just so
embarrassed
he's squat they walked home together in
Christ said come on Meg dinner he
suddenly got an evil looking face but
Pitts did not care he was so in love
with the strong white man Z snap
standing in the front I love you pizza
cry hesitated went to the kitchen
he did not say anything when pews walked
in cried turns around slowly he was
creepy and scary now let's eat he said
as he waved with an knife and a fork
piece backed off cry oh whoa what are
you doing I suddenly wanted to have duck
for dinner pute started to walk a little
bit fast backwards in cry followed and
before he knew it Peters started running
why are you chasing me crying I thought
you loved me
duck is screamed way mooing my way you
have to yell I love done I love dog ki
screams loud
is that good well it's not like you're
narrating would you say yes screams loud
that's it perfect Hughes went to the
bathroom but there were no places to run
or cry what what why was there an or
there puce went to the bathroom but
there were no places to run or and then
Christ smashes I think the idea which is
if like Christ mash into the doors I
impacted you as he like mid-sentence
that's so intense Wow yeah I am such an
intense person that again she's went to
the bathroom but there were no places to
run or dry smashed in the door I like
duck salty he wasn't saying Puetz had
place to go the toilet he jumped up on
the toilet seat pulled the lever and
flushed himself down he tried to hold
his breath but he got choked by the
water anyway Oh No but suddenly he felt
ere he could breathe he took a deep
breath Oh what I went a little overboard
there uh where I am I you're in the
source stupid an Italian voice that kind
of sounds Italian said could it be the
other true love of his so Stefano puce
tried to look after a little gold Tim
statue in the dark but couldn't see
anything
also parity long time no see